Peter, Jordan,
congratulations.
Gentlemen, you're moving forward
into the third and final round
of our Forge of
Fear competition.
Now, in this last round we're
sending you back to your home
forges to work on
an iconic weapon
from cinematic horror history.
You're going to
be building this.
The fireman's ax.
The fireman's ax is
the weapon of choice
for some of the most
terrifying psychopaths
in the horror genre.
From Patrick Bateman
in "American Psycho"
to Jack Torrence in Stanley
Kubrick's "The Shining,"
ironically, this
notorious slasher
was actually designed as
a robust life-saving tool
used by brave firefighters
around the world.
Featuring a strong,
stout ax blade
on one side and a sharp,
spike-like pick on the other,
it's designed to break
through doors and windows,
pry through obstacles,
and clear debris to rescue
people trapped in raging fires.
Gentlemen, you have four days
to build your firemens' axes.
Good luck.
We'll see you then.
[chuckling]
My name is Peter Farquhar.
I'm 56 years old, and
I took up bladesmithing
when I was 14 years old.
My biggest concern
is that I'm going
to do something really
stupid early on, because I
just had a brain fart.
I'm going to try and forge it
in one piece without a weld.
It's time for me
to go to a narrower
chisel that can take
more manageable bites out
of the steel.
I'm going to flood
it with grazing rods,
so we'll have a
nice inlay effect.
One side of the blade,
I have a Chinese dragon,
in memory of my father.
And on the other side, I
did a Norse-style dragon,
in memory of my mother.
Now I'm going to get
the handle ready.
Well, my handle has developed
a crack right up the middle.
That's worrisome.
The judges could
give me a hard time,
so the next thing I did was
I made a brass ferrule that
will hold everything together.
Structurally, I'm
not worried about it,
but I am still upset
with myself that I
made that little mistake.
After that, I wanted to
do something interesting
with the handle, too.
I wound up making a
couple of branding irons
and laying a scale pattern
on by burning it in.
I don't know if I'm
going to win or not,
but I know nobody is going
to forget this thing.
My name's Jordan Jackson.
I'm from Rutherfordton,
North Carolina.
I've been a bladesmith
for about eight years.
I'm 32 years old.
My son is 10 years old.
He's made a few knives, himself.
He gave me very
specific instructions
to make sure that my
blades met parameters,
and he told me not
to quench it too hot.
I got my slot started there, so
I can drift out my handle hold.
Going into the
heat treat, I'm not
really concerned
about warps that much.
My biggest concern is
any of these forge welds
wanting to pop loose.
It's a very delicate process.
If the welds aren't
successful, I'm
gonna have to go all the
way back to square one,
and start all over.
I go with the spot
first, and then I flip
it over and quench the blade.
Oh, yeah.
File skates and it's
absolutely beautiful.
Wanted to add a little bit
of design to the handle,
so I did some tally
marks for a body count.
I think it's going to look cool.
So I'm getting ready to put
the ax head onto the handle.
I slide it on there, tap it
under the handle to make sure
that everything's set good.
Cool.
So now I want to go back on
that hickory handle and sort
of char it a little bit, to make
it look like it's a really old,
found murder weapon.
You don't see an ax
murderer walking around
with a brand new ax
that they just picked
up at the hardware store.
Look at that.
I'm really happy with
how that came out.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the kill test.
Today, I'm going
to take your weapon
and fend it against
this horned demon.
Peter, you're first.
Shall be free it of its soul?
Oh, please.
All right.
Let's do it.
All right, Peter, let's
talk about your ax here.
The ax handle you have
here is wide enough
to where I can get a very good
grip in wielding this weapon.
Your ax head is
very sharp, and more
importantly, sir, it will kill.
Thank you.
All right, Jordan,
you're up next.
Are you ready for this?
- Oh, yeah.
Let's do this.
All right, George, let's
talk about your fireman's ax.
I love the feel, and the
shape of your handle.
The head you have
here is heavier,
so it really penetrates
deep into this demon dummy.
Your edge took no
damage whatsoever,
and I think now we can add
another notch to your handle.
Overall, sir, your
fireman's ax, it will kill.
Thanks, Doug.
That's what I needed.
Hi, guys.
Well, bladesmiths, welcome
to our strength test.
Our horror door chop.
Now, what the axes
do to the door
is secondary to what the
door does to your axes,
but regardless, it's going
to be a hell of a lot of fun.
Now, Peter, you ready to go?
I'm ready.
Let's go.
All right.
Let's do it.
[grunting]
Becky, I'm home.
All right, Peter, nice job.
Everything's still tight.
You got a couple little small
splits there from wedging it.
Your spike is still perfectly
sharp, and same with your edge.
Still razor sharp.
Good job.
Thank you much.
All right, Jordan, you're up.
You ready to give this pup
of a door its medicine?
Oh, yeah.
Let's do it.
[grunting]
All right, Jordan, nice job.
This is a much heavier ax.
Wider handle.
Edge still razor sharp.
Nothing loosened up.
Real nice job.
Awesomme.
Thanks.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to our sharpness test--
the arm chop.
Peter, you're up first.
Are you ready, sir?
I am ready.
All right.
Let's have some hand chops.
All right, Peter.
Sharp edges, and these are
all very clean cuts, sir.
Overall, your
weapon-- it will cut.
Thanks, Doug.
All right, Jordan, your turn.
Sir, are you ready?
- Oh, yeah.
- All right, let's do this.
All right, Jordan, even
though it's heavier,
it is the weight that's expected
of a firemen's ax, because just
let the weight fall into this,
and it cut cleanly on the arm.
Overall, sir, your
weapon, it will cut.
Thanks, Doug.
Well, gentlemen,
we tried to scare you
guys away in this Forge
of Fear competition,
but you both stood up and
showed us you guys have
the skills it takes to be here.
But in this competition,
only one of you guys
will be going home with the
title of "Forged in Fire"
champion, and a
check for $10,000.
The judges have discussed it.
It took a while, but
they made a decision.
Today's "Forged in
Fire" champion is--
Jordan.
Congratulations.
Now, Peter, you did
a phenomenal job,
but unfortunately, your blade is
not going to end up on the wall
today.
And Jay is going
to tell you why.
Peter, you did
a fantastic job,
and you brought us an
ax that I would take
home and use in a heartbeat.
But we have a handle issue.
We do have a crack that
goes all the way through,
and Jordan's design
is much closer
to the example of the
traditional fireman's ax.
And that's why we didn't
choose your weapon today.
Now, Peter, you crushed it
in the first couple of rounds
of this competition, and
you did phenomenally well
in the last round, but
unfortunately, your time
in this competition has ended.
I'm gonna have to
ask you to please
step off the forge floor.
- Thank you, gentlemen.
- Thank you.
Great job, Peter.
You did great.
If I had another piece
of wood lying around,
I would have junked the handle
and started over right then.
But I respect the
decision they made.
Jordan, congratulations, man.
That means you are the
champion of "Forged in Fire,"
and you just won yourself
a check for $10,000.
Congratulations.
I'm super proud of what
I was able to accomplish,
and you know, I just
wanted to make my family
and my community proud.
That thing is a beast.
My name is Jordan Jackson,
and I'm the "Forged in Fire"
champion.